Hi, my name is Steve Souders.
I work at Google, and I'll be
speaking at Google I/O
which is happening
at the end of May,
the 27th and 28th
up in San Francisco.
And I work in Web performance.
I'm the creator of YSlow.
I wrote a book
a couple years ago
called
"High Performance Web Sites,"
and I'm actually
just finishing up a second book.
And writing a book
is a long process.
This one took over a year,
a lot of research.
There's a lot of moving parts.
And luckily,
most of that is behind me,
and I'm entering one of the last
phases of getting a book out,
which is called
"pimping the book."
So I'll be honest,
I'm here partly
to pimp the book.
I also want to spread these
performance best practices.
But the way I do that
is by going around
and talking about the best
practices in my next book,
"Even Faster Web Sites."
So what I typically do
is I'll go to--
You know, I write blog posts.
I release software
related to the book.
But I also go to conferences,
and I do talks.
I don't want to do the same talk
over and over and over again.
So this book,
just like my previous one,
is a collection of about a dozen
performance best practices.
And I'll pick three or four
of those to talk about
at any given conference
and mix it up a little bit.
And I'm happy to say
I've been holding off
on talking about one of these
performance best practices
until Google I/O,
and that one is called
"Going Beyond Gzipping."
And the key behind this one
is an observation.
So this rule
is actually written.
The chapter is authored by my
office mate here at Google,
Tony Gentilcore.
And what he discovered is,
we know that compression
is really important,
the compression
of text responses,
like HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
But it turns out that about 15%
of the world's population
does not get
compressed responses,
even though
their browsers support that.
So come out to Google I/O.
Come to my talk,
"Even Faster Web Sites,"
and find out why 15%
of the world
doesn't get compressed responses
and what you can do about it.
Thanks.